[Music]
you've been stranded
thousands of miles from home with no
money or possessions
such a predicament would make many
people despair and
curse their awful fate but for zeno of
cyprus
it became the foundation of his life's
work and legacy
the once wealthy merchant lost
everything when he was
shipwrecked in athens around 300 bce
with not much else to do he wandered
into a bookshop
became intrigued by reading about
socrates and proceeded to seek out and
study
with the city's noted philosophers
as xeno began educating his own students
he
originated the philosophy known as
stoicism
whose teachings of virtue tolerance and
self-control
have inspired generations of thinkers
and leaders
the name stoicism comes from the stoa
poikile
the decorated public colonnade where
zeno and his disciples
gathered for discussion today we
colloquially use the word stoic
to mean someone who remains calm under
pressure
and avoids emotional extremes
but while this captures important
aspects of stoicism
the original philosophy was more than
just an attitude
the stoics believed that everything
around us operates according to a web of
cause and effect
resulting in a rational structure of the
universe
which they called logos and while we may
not
always have control over the events
affecting us
we can have control over how we approach
things
rather than imagining an ideal society
the stoic
tries to deal with the world as it is
while pursuing self-improvement
through four cardinal virtues practical
wisdom
the ability to navigate complex
situations in a logical
informed and calm manner temperance
the exercise of self-restraint and
moderation in
all aspects of life justice
treating others with fairness even when
they have done wrong
and courage not just in extraordinary
circumstances
but facing daily challenges with clarity
and integrity
as seneca one of the most famous roman
stoics wrote
sometimes even to live is an act of
courage
but while stoicism focuses on personal
improvement
it's not a self-centered philosophy
at a time when roman law is considered
slaves as
property seneca called for their humane
treatment
and stress that we all share the same
fundamental humanity
nor does stoicism encourage passivity
the idea is that only people who have
cultivated virtue and self-control in
themselves
can bring positive change in others
one of the most famous stoic writers was
also one of rome's greatest emperors
over the course of his 19-year reign
stoicism gave
marcus aurelius the resolve to lead the
empire
through two major wars while dealing
with the loss of many of his children
centuries later marcus's journals would
guide and comfort nelson mandela
through his 27-year imprisonment during
his struggle for racial equality in
south africa
after his release and eventual victory
mandela stressed
peace and reconciliation believing that
while the injustices of the past
couldn't be
changed his people could confront them
in the present
and seek to build a better more just
future
stoicism was an active school of
philosophy for several centuries in
greece and rome
as a formal institution it faded away
but its influence has continued to this
day
christian theologians such as thomas
aquinas have
admired and adopted its focus on the
virtues
and there are parallels between stoic
ataraxia
or tranquility of mind and the buddhist
concept
of nirvana one particularly influential
stoic
was the philosopher epictetus who wrote
that suffering
stems not from the events in our lives
but from our judgments
about them this has resonated strongly
with modern psychology
and the self-help movement for example
rational emotive behavioral therapy
focuses on changing the self-defeating
attitudes people form about their life
circumstances
there's also victor frankel's logo
therapy
informed by frankl's own time as a
concentration camp prisoner
logo therapy is based on the stoic
principle that we can harness our
willpower
to fill our lives with meaning even in
the bleakest situations
[Music]
you